good morning heck it's tuesday you know
what let's go outside
sometimes it really does feel like the
world is gonna roll me
i feel like a very small boat on very
high
seas being tossed this way and that by
forces so much larger than myself that i
can't even comprehend them
but alone control them anyway when that
feeling crashes over me
i find it helpful to go outside it's
technically only the first day of autumn
here
but the air is already crisp and smells
of fallen leaves
in past years it always felt like autumn
would arrive all at once
i'd be flying home from some trip and
look out the airplane window and see
that the leaves had changed
or i'd leave my house one morning and
notice i needed a jacket
but now of course time is unfolding
differently and so autumn has arrived
slowly
but also with so much more uncertainty
and even menace i find a lot of
consolation in being outside right now
but i'm not quite sure why maybe it's
because nature
is still preceding a pace even as so
much else isn't
like this morning i was thinking of a
mary oliver poem
i go down to the shore in the morning
and depending on the hour
the waves are rolling in or moving out
and i say oh i am miserable
what shall what should i do and the sea
says in its lovely voice excuse me
i have work to do this is a stark
contrast from the way nature's
indifference was imagined earlier like
in say herman melville's moby dick where
we read of the demonic indifference with
which the white whale tore his hunters
and that the white whale shadows forth
the heartless voids and immensities of
the universe
and so the idea that terrified melville
that the heartless universe doesn't
particularly care about us
comforts the speaker in mary oliver's
poem and i have to say
i'm team oliver on this one i'm glad the
world goes on orbiting the sun
regardless of what i do i'm glad the
earth is not made for me
but instead that i am made for the earth
and also of it i've read a lot of old
novels where the characters moods change
with the weather
you know like how a dark and stormy
night outside also means a dark and
stormy night inside the heart of our
protagonist or whatever
that always used to make me roll my eyes
but now i see that it
wasn't just a metaphor the closer you
are to the outside world
the more that world can shape your sense
of well-being
same's true of the internet come to
think of it of course this isn't
absolute
you bring yourself to the weather just
like you bring yourself to everything
else
but we don't exist independently from
the weather
or from the world or from history or
from anything and this is where the idea
that nature is indifferent to us
starts to break down for me because the
thing is
we are nature and we need not be
indifferent toward ourselves and one
another
or toward life more generally it is not
quite accurate to say that the ocean
is wondrous or monstrous in its
indifference to us
because the ocean isn't indifferent to
us we move it around with our sea walls
and
land reclamation projects we change its
overall size and biodiversity
by our choices we move the oceans around
and they move us around we depend on the
oceans
and they depend on us humans are nothing
if not wildly utterly
dependent and like the sea says in its
lovely voice
we have work to do may the knowledge of
our interdependence hold fast
even in physical isolation and may
the work to get ourselves and each other
through
keep us warm in the cold months to come
hank i'll see you on friday
this video contains a clue just like all
my recent
videos do but that's the clue